the quite a lot of divergent stories
it's not like there's one single story
for us uh to tell so if we look at
england in particular let's kind of look
at the big picture so there's there's
our map and we're going to keep that
updated as results come through you can
see at the moment you know we're about
halfway in terms of the council's number
of councils uh counted across these
english uh local elections we're talking
about councils here and this is each
this kind of departure board is showing
you who has control of each different
council so you're not talking about
seats here you're talking about who has
the majority on the different councils
obviously red for labour that's gray for
no overall control where there isn't
control uh or indeed in some cases
independent control then you've got blue
obviously and then the lib dems uh in
orange you can see uh as well but if we
actually kind of dig into the numbers
one of the striking uh trends that we've
seen is happening in london so let's
look at the story in london and bear in
mind as i say there is not one single
nationwide story as you're going to see
in a moment but in london it's pretty
clear what's going on labour already it
was just labor stronghold to start with
but they have really reinforced their
support actually if you start over here
have a look at overall london seats okay
because there you get the picture of
what's going on here just look at how
many seats seats across councils in
london that we've had counted so far so
we're kind of about a thousand so far
just look at labour's dominance in
london 648
of those seats that we have so far up by
43 and they were already very strong
indeed remember what we're doing with
these elections is we're comparing it to
the last time these same council seats
were up for election back in 2018 that
was a really strong year for labor so
any increase is as far as labor is
concerned good news in london up by 43.
lib dems up a little bit there uh in
london as well but the striking thing is
you've got these kind of totemic seats
totemic councils like westminster
which has been conservative held
basically since it was created back in
1964
labor up by 13 seats they're taking 13
and taking control of westminster
council but one's worth as well uh
conservative this is again one of these
conservative strongholds one of these
totemic seats atomic councils
conservatives down by eight labour up uh
by eight seats on monsworth and if we
just take a look back through history
get a sense of just how control
of uh this council in wandsworth has
changed over time
you can see what we're looking at here
so since 1978 it's been held by the
conservatives controlled by the
conservatives and for around that period
we're looking at that's the end of the
1970s there for around that period you
can see labour in the conservatives in
kind of relatively neck and neck but
just look at what happens through the
90s through the 2000s conservatives
absolutely dominant there in south
london in worth but look at what's
happened here with these results labor
has overtaken the conservatives now to
take control of wandsworth that is a big
moment and kistama will be very happy
and deep with that but it's not like
you're seeing that replicated across all
of england so bring back the england map
and now have a look at some of these
places which you might have thought
labor might have a chance for for
instance hartley paul how about hartley
paul well it was no overall control
before
these elections but labour might have
been hoping given uh that they have seen
some kind of polling success
in this red wall area of the the uk they
might have been hoping that they could
get up get the number of seats uh on
this council up instead uh no change at
all so still just 11. so they haven't
actually kind of progressed and
increased their numbers in hartlepool
and in england as a whole they're not
necessarily doing quite as well as they
might have hoped and if you have a look
at different regions
of england this is a striking thing okay
so look in the south so at the very top
there you can see in the south this is
the change in the share of the vote the
conservatives down very sharply indeed
labor down only a bit look in the north
labour actually down compared to last
time around that was their high point
1998 so not doing quite as well as they
might have hoped so that's the point
then they're doing not quite as well as
they might have hoped it one final point
though sophie worth noting the lib dems
up pretty strongly uh in most parts of
england and when you look at the
different councils we're talking about
well this one i want to just focus on to
finish with hull kingston upon hull you
can see there that has gone orange it's
gone over to the lib dams they've gained
it from labor that will be seen as a big
moment as indeed as in west west
oxfordshire talismanic seat again for
the conservatives but they have lost
control thanks to big increases from the
lib dem so you've got lots of things
going on all around england and we'll
bring you the story from other parts of
the uk as well